königin finden sie dass sie eine
vernünftige könige sind unbedingt finden
sie dass sie mich richtig behandeln
auf jeden anlass kann auch nicht sein
ich hoffe die leute ich hab ja grad mit
den kilos aufgenommen also für euch was
gestern und aber die königin ein
bisschen böse zu mir und ich nehme das
gerade direkt im anschluss auf ich mache
es mir die bösen blöcke weg die der
kinostar gebaut hat und ich werde
erstmal die ganzen ob sie töten weil es
hakt er echt heftig nein das ist ja echt
nicht mehr fahrbar hier aber das ist
richtig geil weil ich dadurch richtig
richtig richtig richtig viel erfahrung
bekomme mein bogen geht einfach kein
bisschen kaputt das ist so krass
dieser bogen kann einfach nicht kaputt
gehen und küsste also ich mach das jetzt
glaub ich so lange bis ich ja ich muss
auf jeden fall meine rüstung die stadt
noch auf an breaking verzaubern und dann
wäre ich eigentlich sogar schon bereit
für einen angriff auf irgendein anderes
als wenn irgendein anderer einer anderen
person auf dem außer anderen stadt
online ist wie beispielsweise nicht also
ich denke so gegen roth pilz würde ich
mich schon trauen eine schlechte
verzauberung erging rotwild würde ich
mich trauen ging schaffe würde ich mich
trauen gegen
dann gibt es da noch alles totaler komme
weiß ich nicht wieder aufgestellt ist
aber die haben alle schon diese extra
und gelb-rot jemand alles schon diese
coolen auf warum ist nicht so laut
eigentlich egal ich lasse mir das mal so
laut weil dann rede ich automatisch
lauter und imposanter ich fresse riches
break naja ich hab mal ein paar sachen
hier wieder rein ist fast voll hier
richtig gut
das wäre cool wenn man etwas an ich habe
geputzt
sollte ihr kommt alle da rein bla bla
bla bla die kacke ist einfach ich glaube
ich sollte dieses dürfe den hier mal
ausmachen
du kommst daran ihre miniatur ja zuerst
muss ich sage mal ganz kurz da kommt
kann ich die jazz platten packen damit
helfen und ihm freut euch auf einen
export beste jetzt kann ich all' tag
dauert aber es gar nicht mehr los doch
nichts mehr da kommen ganz geile sachen
raus aber in die plötzlich so ihr kommt
herein und dann werde ich meine rüstung
jetzt mal verzaubern erwartet das kann
immer noch daran tun so ich fand die
aufnahme gestern relativ cool mit chaos
eigentlich los ist echtes ist immer mit
krach kann man gut aufnehmen pfennig
sonder-edition wir natürlich erst mal
aus wo muss denn überall noch was drauf
an breaking drei protection da muss noch
so treffer drauf hier ist ja noch gar
nix drauf da nicht mal an breaking
runter und packt da kann ich da nicht
noch fünf tage habe ich jetzt noch als
hier schon das auch ganz wild darauf auf
die hosen muss noch sold at und dann
wären wir durch erstmal mit den
hauptplatz warum also dann kommt er noch
an breaking the waves ananas und dann
werde ich gleich auch noch mal bei
twitter ihr könnt mir alle bei twitter
folgen und bei instagram mach ich das ja
auch immer wenn ich aufnehme
da kommen auch mal viele coole
kommentare zur oecd
pp bezüglich was ich machen soll
tiger woods und nein
hier kommt herein da kommen ja immer
recht geile kommentare wie
beispielsweise tanja kannst du immer das
handys bauen und diesen passt und
blablabla so richtig richtig coole
sachen auf jeden fall freue ich freue
mich wirklich immer wenn ich eure ganzen
kommentare lese allerdings wird bei
youtube echt wenig kommentiert macht
mich ein bisschen traurig das liegt
nicht an euch ihr seid alle wirklich
aktiv dabei aber es liegt daran dass man
einfach jetzt neuerdings diese google+
scheiße da benötigt ich glaube das war's
die ganzen mob sind tot
ich habe danach ich bekomme das heftig
gehört von kilos wie half die app ich
will auch die magischen ezb apple man
jetzt was heißt ein klacks klettern kann
sich einmal sterben hier das war's dann
keinem optimierte school is fresh so ihr
kommt da noch an da kommt ihr noch bla
bla bla bla
ich brauche aber nicht living metal ex
sie gut ist sie besser ist nicht gut die
kann auch in den müll
wenn die achse die ich habe diese diese
frederik sie dann mit einem fahrzeug
etwas geht so die diamant aktiv fast
kampusch die brauche ich auch nicht mehr
ich brauche ich nicht der ist das was
ich mir hier gekostet habe den rest
broich eigentlich auch den bogen wollen
nicht miniatur herzalter das ist so geil
dass noch ein partner so da muss doch
sollte da drauf
0 level perfekt auf allen ist sollte
hier ist schon an breaking 3 ein break
im 3 das kein an breaking aber jetzt
noch protection 4
und da auch da muss hier noch an
tracking drauf dann mache ich einfach
schon mal die mob falle wieder an dass
ich dann halt gleich direkt weiter
farben gehen kann und erst mal knicks
machen nix übrigens das ist so kenne ich
fordere dass wir eine neue königin
bekommen ich war ja anfangs heftig
zufrieden mit unserer königin
aber wenn ich jetzt sage zum beispiel
wenn jetzt kommt ich frage jetzt meine
app bzw die königin erstmal nix habe ich
schon gemacht
ob sie mich dann liebt wenn sie mich
liebt ist alles in ordnung dann weiß ich
dass es zufall war aber wenn sie jetzt
nein sagt dann ist halt ein bisschen
karneval
also ich frage die königin liebst du
dich oder liebst du mich nicht
und ja also ich habe wieder hier alles
aktiviert
ja ich glaube das sieht man da und ein
bisschen hatte das müssen wir erkennen
dass ich alles aktiviert egal
meine damen und herren ich frage die
königin ob sie mich liebt liebst du mich
was für auf zu fragen
scheiß königin alter scheint ein knick
sei nie wieder krieg sind knicks von mir
hier guck ich hoffe dir vorbei ich
könnte jetzt immerhin scheiß königin ich
will neue könig wer glaubt das nicht
mehr kandidiere ich wirklich als könig
damit sich hier so einiges ändern
und jetzt geht es mir wieder ein
bisschen paranoia gemacht wie schon
paranoia und jetzt und ihre erfahrung
pur und die stars ananas und planbar bam
bam und sind nahezu alle schon wieder
drin lassen alle tot
die rest kannst wie das bin zu
kommunizieren die ganzen sachen hier die
ich nicht so sein dass ich hier
verbraucht es eigentlich ein schwert ich
weiß gar nicht viel das kostet egal ich
werde jetzt erstmal meinen christel body
muss ein bisschen mehr verzaubern
ach nee nicht jedoch kristlbauer da muss
auch noch ein bisschen mehr drauf ich
wollte auch noch beck eigentlich
runternehmen habe ich noch action runter
genommen hab ich kacke dem objekt auf
gibt da kann ich da nicht noch drauf
packen
aber man mir gut geschrieben welche wie
die verzauberung heißt war das blatt
27 jahr ist könnte bleibt sein
wahr ist bleibt das schadet es mit ihm
besprechen können egal wo warst du mich
denn hier zum spiel hat von hinten ab du
besser wie kommen die überhaupt raus es
ist nach der gut es könne dann eventuell
daran liegen ja sie ziehen mein herz und
mein mann schwert ab ich sollte auch
vielleicht mal meinen hier wieder
anmachen
jetzt kommt einfach alle items sie da
liegen sie zu mir direkt was hat das
geil an diesem christel bonner ich ziehe
den ganz kurz ran und er ist putz direkt
in alle tot da drin alle wenn tot
vermutlich sterben hab ich sehe gar
nicht wo er welche sind war das müsste
doch eigentlich erst mal reichen wo
jeder alles eingesammelt
das krasse ist dass dieses ding so stark
ist dass es sogar die sachen aus
mülleimern rauszieht
so muss erstmal nicht auf 7 20 level
egal erstmal die rüstung muss an
breaking bekommen an breaking 34
anbrechen kann hier drauf in breaking 10
na gut das ist so geil
dieser bogen ich liebe den ich liebe
euch alle dass er mir das so geil in
kommentare geschrieben habt dass ich mir
diesen bogen holen soll
übrigens ich war am wochenende feiern in
herford aber manchmal habe ich ja gesagt
ich wurde erkannt ich wurde drei mal
erkannt dass relativ witzig weil
eigentlich vor allem die tatsache dass
mich mittlerweile so viele mädels gucken
es ist heftig bei facebook sind mehr
mädels als jungs die meiner seite
geleitet haben dass es mega crash und
ich schreibe auch so viele mädels also
irgendwie dass ich mir so dass sich luca
film weitermachen soll so mary
live-videos weil die halter nahezu nur
elf gucken wir werden da bilder
geschickt ich würde jetzt auch als ich
feiern war als ich tanzen war kam so ein
mädchen an die auch relativ süß war
eigentlich so ja bla bla bla
diese videos richtig richtig krass
eigentlich von dem ich nie gedacht hätte
dass dies meine videos schauen man kann
es eh schon einschätzen dass zum
beispiel jetzt mal krass übertrieben
genommen dass ein 60-jähriger
familienvater wahrscheinlich nicht meine
videos gucken wir so erhaltet ihr
zusätzlich dass diese 60 jahre alter
waren aber ich hab das schon anbrechen
ein break im rücken da wo ich habe alle
an breaking drauf jetzt muss nur noch
protection protection vitalsten
protection
so warte mal protection 4 würde 410
kosten dementsprechend brauche ich 28
level das ist wieder so eine komplette
vor wir sind schon bei zehn minuten
alter bei zehn minuten meine damen und
herren
entweder diese krieg im bogen nicht doch
besser da klatschen ja mit meinen wagen
geklaut alter ist mein ein und alles
dieser bogen ist so geil ist es heftig
und wo sich dieses ihren ratings booms
als portal und export gibt mehr fahren
los zehn level gut ich mache die erst
mal ganz kurz wieder aus und geh mal
ganz kurz kennen weil irgendwie bei tag
fühle ich mich dann mal sicherer
du hast das ruhig hier ist das schön
diese ruhe
wir können euch mal die königin fragen
was sie denn meint ob ich jetzt in der
nächsten folge meint das ist jetzt eine
ganz normale fragen
ich frage sie jetzt erst ob ich in der
nächsten folge mein haus bauen soll und
dann ob ich wenn sie dann ein sagt ob
ich in der nächsten folge die stadt
verschönern soll
und sie hat jetzt da oder ob ich weiter
so mit ausrüsten soll soll ich in der
nächsten folge weil meine sehr verehrte
königin die ich so liebe solche der
nächsten folge mein haus bauen
fick dich alter da frage ich ob ich mein
haus weiter bauen soll höre mit dem
quatsch auf das kein quatsch das wird
ein schönes haus werde ich ihr noch
beweisen
ich frage ich frage die zweite frage gar
nicht mehr ich bin das beleidigt sie
sagt dass man dass mein haus quatsch ist
mit sowas mit solchen leuten muss ich
mich nicht abgeben
es kann nicht wahr sein das ist einfach
nur traurig traurig es helga die ganze
sache die ich nicht mehr brauche
kurzum ein bogen hallo hallo bogen soll
dann kommen hier noch ein paar sachen
rein ist auch schon voll
kev könnte jetzt einmal aussortieren ihr
okay ich sollte mich nicht beschweren
weil da ja ich habe selbst nicht geheizt
hat beste leben studiert sie einfach
rein so der müll muss da noch bisschen
rein
diese ganzen areals bringen eh nix amory
femory so dass da ohne goldene feder die
ag schon vorher euch alle brauche ich
noch ein pfeil das möchte diesen die
mordfall ist doch eher aus oder
wenn man sich das mal anguckt wie
schnell die erfahrung steigt mit dem
kölner fortune und diesen bogen
na gut die opfer lässt nahezu leer von
daher kann man das jetzt nicht so gut
sie setzt nicht so heftig alles leer so
eins kann ich schon verzaubert mit
protection 4
so und jetzt brauche ich aber noch ein
paar level so dass sich da eben rein
aus kurz fressen kann man jetzt habe ich
diese folge nahezu wieder relativ wenig
erreicht eigentlich also ich habe viel
erreicht aber es war glaube ich als
zuschauer für die zuschauer recht
langweilige folge will ich jetzt mal so
grob behaupten
und ich weiß ja nicht ob ihr das so als
langweilig empfinden weil ich könnte
noch irgendwas produktives machen ich
könnte ja noch mitten im haus bauen
möchte endlich erst anfang wirklich
komplett vorbereitet bin habe ich nicht
noch irgendwo eine dame in cheste
diesmal so hätte ja genau hier passt die
ich mir einfach jetzt hier so hinstellen
kann
mosimann inventar drin ist so sachen die
ich halte die sachen kann ich erst mal
ein legen den bogen habe ich das man
inventar das ist nicht mehr im landtag
und die sachen kann ich auch mal hier
rein tun so als miniatur herz kommt
nachher effekt habe ich mich mal mit und
packt die auch mal hier an
ich brauche nur dieses blöde aluminium
an kann ich mir diese zusatz herzen
machen
wir können einfach irgendwann richtig
weit fliegen wieder mit ross block 8 in
solchen kräften den wolf mit kräften
stimmt das hätte ich auch machen können
glock raste aus roten fleisches nice das
war es behindert als ob ich ihm dafür
die lizenzen gebe das ja nix das ist ja
gut vielleicht ein bisschen länger das
zu kräften aber das war echt nix aber
ich hatte sogar noch einen baum an dass
man mir bestimmt letzte folge leute
geschrieben dass noch ein hatte
ich finde unsere königin die hat es
verdient zu sterben
kuba wo die erste und musik wieder mein
code hier eingehen beim falsch ich bin
mein coach ach so ja doch ein kurzes 25
folge fast vorbei ja königin finden sie
dass sie eine vernünftige königin sind
finden sie dass sie mich richtig
behandeln
doch kommen man das kann auch nicht sein
ich hoffe die dakar ich hoffe mit dieser
kkl dort gar nicht weinen hier
das soll diesen denken muss nach außen
oder so dass nicht mehr drin
ich brauche ich noch level um hier
protection draufzupacken aber sonst
protection viel altes protection 3 drauf
überall
vielleicht kann ich dann noch beiden
einen höher geben protection 4 1 doch
ist doch drauf an tracking 3 an breaking
drei andretti green racing drivers on
the salt ever sold at protection vier
protection vier protection vier kein
protection aber ich kann da schon ein
bischen protection draufpacken
ob zwei sollte gehen 2
gut dann haben die rüstung jetzt
verzaubert was wir in dieser folge
geschafft haben wir haben noch drei
minuten
ja gut dann sollte ich das jetzt mal
ganz kurz ein ganz klein bisschen als
sind den materialien die ich für ein
haus baut sich erst mal ganz kurz die
sachen die ich jetzt gerade erst mal
nicht brauche deshalb im hausbau ich
kann hier schon mal den boden so ein
bisschen ausheben da muss ich auch gar
nicht im boden ausheben
hier schwebt die dornen ohne ekel de
vries snoop dogg ihr könnt mir auch wie
schon letzte folge weiter das kann nie
sagen dass es hier so kacke ausgehoben
wurde
ihr könnt mir wie auch schon letzte
folge gesagt einfach bei twitter
twitter.com / konkreter folgen und mir
da tipps geben
bezüglich hausbau bezüglich exit hat
kann an die seine
schreibt mir mal wer das hier ausgehoben
hat das ist besser für eine kacke
bezüglich exit allgemein und zwar fällt
mir auch eigentlich gerade auf das ich
theoretisch nicht ich dachte damit das
schneller ab aber ich könnte mir eine
schaufel machen habe ich fresse
resistenzen als lizenzen diamanten man
hier nicht welche drin
dann wollen noch zwei sticks surf sticks
da sind zwei sticks
jetzt laufe ich hier kurz noch zum
crafting table das will ich in dieser
folge noch eben schaffen
soso presserat die kann ich ja jetzt
eigentlich spade es nicht schoppel
komisch
die kann jetzt eigentlich kostenlos
verzaubert efficiency stirbt an breaking
plattform alles ausgepackt so jetzt
müsste es ja damit viel schneller gehen
oder mich mal grob sagen oh oh oh oh wow
das ist einfach nur 1 1
dudek ich das erst mal was mit meinem
kristlbauer mit einem cross creek
muss in einer min weg sonst krieg krieg
ich den wegpunkt gesetzt nehmen so ist
das krass ich muss ich klicke nur einmal
tschuldigung auch wenn ich mein schoko
damit schlage sechs herzen abzug was du
bist ein vernünftiges chocobo das liebt
mich aber unsere königin ist scheiße
nicht wirklich auf dieser ebene ich
eigentlich sein so dass jetzt einfach
mal ein bisschen weil moment wie man das
geht er relativ schnell wenn ich damit
fertig bin
das sollte jetzt nicht so lange dauern
meine lebensfreude
wir sind fertig hier mit dem haus
ausheben hier könnte ich die blöcke
wieder hinsetzen
wir sind fertig mit dem haus ausheben
von unten ihr könnt mir jetzt alle in
die kommentare schreiben so viel
ausprobieren wollt und was dann nachher
öfter geschrieben wurde werde ich dann
als untergrund material hier benutzen
untergrund material ist vielleicht
falschen habe wie das ganze als
geheimtipp mit dem untergrund und dann
wird daraus quasi mein haus entstehen
oder es fehlt noch
so sieht bisher alt aussieht noch nicht
aus wie ein haus aber wird noch freunde
hier kommt dann mein chocobos starken
mir wird auch öfters geschrieben die
dann ausfiel zu groß hier kommt aber
auch die essensausgabe nach da vorne
rein hier vorne
wie wird eigentlich auch sowie der
chocobos stall oder ich mache hier auch
noch die essensausgabe
das kann ich echt machen dass ich dann
quasi hier warte 1234 1234
sodann die essensausgabe hin mache aber
gut das muss ich jetzt entschieden
werden
da kommt dann auch noch so ein pfeiler
hin da ist es quasi alles direkt nebenan
das multifunktionale list und dann will
ich sagen
viel spaß noch bei dem was ihr heute
noch macht ich hoffe euch jetzt gefallen
wenn ja dann lasst doch einfach einen
daumen hoch da dann sehen uns jetzt mal
wieder mal gut und